Hey it's me Destin
We like to do a lot of weird things with our cameras.
So one thing I was going to show you is how to do some real neat things with open-shutter photography.
Basically, you open the shutter for an extended period of time
and then you do something neat
and then you close the shutter and then you look at your image.
So you can compile a bunch of different things.
So, we're out here in my driveway, it's very dark, as you can see.
My brother in law, Shawn, he's got a light on me so you can see me.
We have a few things we can play with
we've got a frisbee that changes colors.
We're going to do some open-shutter photography with that.
That will be really neat.
We have a ball.
A pretty neat ball, that you'll see
It's a light-up ball that when you bounce it it turns on
So we will get to see some nice parabolic motion with that, that'll be neat.
And we have one other thing you might have never heard of.
It's called an X-Zylo
It has these little glow sticks that I'm activating here
[Glowstick cracking]
It's like a gyroscope that you throw though the air like a football. It's pretty neat.
So, we're going to do some open-shutter photography, show you some neat things
And afterwards, we're going to show you some things you can do in your own house.
Anyway, we'll see how it goes.
Let's check it out
OK, we're going to start off just showing you what we're doing
I'm wearing a white LED on my head so you can see me.
Hey, Shawn, wave the frisbee!
Shawn's wearing red so you can see him.
This is kind of how it looks like... normal, this is how dark it is.
♫Lightout by Anthony Raijekov♫
That was pretty cool! Now we're going to go and start some open-shutter photography.
(Shawn) Are you ready for conic sections?
And parabolic motion?
(Destin) Yeah baby!
(Shawn) Oh Yeah!
♫Lightout by Anthony Raijekov♫
Next phase is the X-Zylo
It's just like the other ones except instead of just gravity that we're going to play with
now we're going to throw in a tourqe vector.
So, spin stabilized and also aerodynamically stabilized.
This should do some strange things.
We'll check it out -How 'bout it Shawn?
(Shawn) Oh yeah!
♫Lightout by Anthony Raijekov♫